- [Man] Boeing's popular 787 Dreamliner
is facing a new manufacturing defect,
which might sound familiar.
- This is another blow for Boeing.
- [Man] The defect could
take three weeks to address,
which means airlines won't
be receiving Dreamliners
in time for much of the
busy summer travel season.
- [Man] Recent issues
with the plane makers
wide body aircraft stretched
back to last summer.
Since then, the defects have
prompted regulatory review,
a halting of deliveries,
a pile up of more than a hundred planes
and are now pressuring
Boeing's bottom line.
- This is not a situation
Boeing wants to be in
at this point.
Right now it can't deliver
its most popular wide body aircraft.
It's almost as if the company like Apple
couldn't deliver laptops.
- [Man] So what are the
issues with the Dreamliner
and how did Boeing get here?
First, a bit of background,
the 787 Dreamliner
made its commercial debut in 2011.
- Costs all sorts of
possibilities for new routes,
new efficiencies for airlines,
a better passenger experience
and then it wounded up on the ground.
- [Man] In early 2013, a fire broke out
aboard an empty Dreamliner in Boston,
sparked by battery problems
that later surfaced
on another Dreamliner in Japan.
- In two weeks time, we saw
two cases of battery failures
on the 787 and the grounding
of the entire fleet
by the FAA.
- So the Dreamliner had to
emerge from that experience
and regain the confidence of airlines
and the traveling public.
- [Man] The 787 Is now one of Boeing's
most popular aircraft,
more than 60 airlines,
including American and United,
have added 787s to their fleet.
The Dreamliner is unique, as
it was Boeing's first plane
designed largely by other companies.
Its primary structure is made mostly
from composite materials for efficiency.
- Because the Dreamliners
structure is new in the world
of aircraft manufacturing,
Boeing and the FAA are learning
how it's composite materials
and where those materials
join age over time.
- [Man] So fast forward, nearly
a decade of flights later,
to August of last year,
when Boeing voluntarily
grounded eight Dreamliners
found with two different
production defects
in the same location.
- For an aircraft manufacturer
to do that on its own
is something that you
really don't see that often.
- [Man] The defects were
outlined in an August 31st
internal federal aviation
administration memo,
which was reviewed and then reported on
by the Wall Street Journal.
- We first reported about
the Dreamliner issues
in September, when the FAA
launched a high level review
of Boeing's Dreamliner
manufacturing processes.
At that time, Boeing
and the FAA were trying
to get their heads around the
problem and they focused on
one general area of the aircraft.
- [Man] Specifically, the FAA
memo says they were looking
at nonconforming sections
of the rear fuselage
or body of the plane that fell short
of its own engineering standards.
The first defect had to do
with how Boeing used shims
or the material that fills
the gaps between sections
of the fuselage.
The second stemmed from variations
in the smoothness of the fuselage skin.
- While the two types of defects,
independent of each other,
didn't pose an immediate safety risk,
together in the same section,
are deemed to potentially introduce a risk
of a structural integrity
problem in extreme circumstances.
- [Man] Then the following day,
Boeing flagged a third issue,
this one with sections
of the Dreamliners tail
that were clamped together
improperly during assembly.
- It's not a question of
immediate structural integrity.
It's a question of whether
or not they introduced
premature aging and if so,
what does that mean for
the Dreamliners in service
and how often they need
to be serviced and fixed?
- [Man] In a recent internal
video Boeing explained
how thin these gaps are.
- If you started at the
tail of the airplane,
just walking to the front,
each of those sections,
when we bring them together,
is within five thousandths of an inch.
You'll hear people talk of gaps.
It's really not what you would
normally think of as a gap.
- [Man] The next month, in October,
Boeing halted delivery of the Dreamliners.
- Halting deliveries is a big deal
and in fact that means Boeing
can't sell the products.
- [Man] Customers largely
pay Boeing on delivery.
Prior to the halt, many
of Boeing's commercial
deliveries were Dreamliners,
as the 737 Max remained grounded
following two fatal crashes
of that aircraft.
- Boeing was at that point,
a month away from getting
the FAA's okay to again,
fly passengers on 737 Max
and suddenly it couldn't get
its other popular aircraft,
the Dreamliner, off the lot either.
- [Man] Then with delivery still halted,
The plane maker expanded its inspections
of the Dreamliner in December,
after it found instances
of the smoothness issue on
new sections of the plane.
- At that point, it became
clear that the problem
wasn't going away as quickly
as we might've thought earlier.
- [Man] In mid-March, the FAA
took back Boeing's authority
to inspect and sign off
on several Dreamliners awaiting delivery,
saying it would conduct
the checks instead.
- It had echoes of what happened
after the 737 Max crashes.
This action by the FAA was a sign of
its increasing scrutiny
when it came to overseeing
the manufacturing process
of the Dreamliner.
- [Man] But later that month,
Boeing resumed Dreamliner deliveries,
taking what looked like the first step
toward moving past these issues.
In April, the company's
CEO, David Calhoun,
told investors the 787
delivery pause was an example
of the company trying to solve
its manufacturing issues.
- We've taking actions over
this, really hard actions,
over the course of this
year to stop things
when we see an issue and get
'em fixed once and for all.
- [Man] Then, in late May,
deliveries were halted again,
as the FAA requested more
information from Boeing
about its proposed solution
for catching and addressing
the defects before handing
over the planes to customers.
- Boeing was hoping that
it could get FAA approval
for the methodology to inspect,
using a mix of physical
inspections and analysis.
- [Man] With those discussions ongoing,
Boeing found the latest
defect around early July.
This time on part of the aircraft
known as the forward pressure bulkhead
at the front of the plane.
- So it's going to complicate
the process that was underway
of going, trying to prove to the FAA
that its methodology was sound.
- [Man] It's still unclear
when the latest issue
will be resolved, though
Boeing said it could take
at least three weeks to address.
- [Stan] What we're doing on the 787
is a methodical program,
reviewing the airplane from tip to tail,
in a way that's safe and
compliant for our customers
and our regulators.
- [Man] Meanwhile, finished
Dreamliners are piling up.
More than a hundred planes await delivery.
Boeing has slowed production on the plane
and said it now expects
to deliver less than half
of its 787 inventory this year.
- [Man] The slowdown is likely to ripple
into Boeing's vast supply network
and for some weeks and months,
it's going to mean that
Boeing's airline customers
have to wait longer to
get their new Dreamliners.
- [Man] It's unclear whether
these manufacturing issues
will matter in the long run.
- Whether or not there
is any long-term impacts,
good or bad, to Boeing's
reputation remains to be seen.
For now, the Dreamliner is
still a very popular aircraft
and has an excellent safety record.
(calm music)